the next lecture is going to be given by
Professor bank Holmstrom and here are
his stats he he was born in Helsinki he
got his PhD from Stanford and he's now a
professor of economics and management at
MIT and I would like to invite professor
Holmstrom to come up here and give his
lecture thank you to myself I want to
thank the Academy the Royal Academy for
bestowing us with this great great honor
and thank you all for coming a lot of
friends here it's very difficult to see
from here where they are but it's much
appreciated
and I must say that I am delighted to
share this price with with my somewhat
senile friend Oliver who is is very
close to me I want to try to say
something about my book obviously but I
also want to try to convey in this
lecture a little bit how how we think or
I at least think about theory high
materialist and and you know economics
may sometimes seem like it's either
incomprehensibly stupid or trivial but
nothing in between and I'm going to try
to explain some of the thinking that may
seem obvious but actually requires some
further thought and and so that was
telling something about my journey here
is is basically the plan a narrative of
how I got into incentives and and
and what their key steps in one of the
sense of what I've done
especially motivating workers so in some
sense it complements Oliver's talking
that it I'm focused more on contracts
broadly construed and I'm I'm also
focused on on contacts within the firm
rather than between firms I want to say
a word about how I got into it because
it's unusual slightly unusual
I didn't plan to be an economist and I
didn't start off on that track I went
off I was a mathematician and applied
mathematician I went to work for a firm
in Finland that's called awesome it was
one of the top ten films in in and a
progressive form it's a big component it
had thirty factories or so and I was
hired as for a very specific task which
was to to implement a big corporate
planning model corporate planning models
of that sort don't exist anymore and I
hope I hope for some of the reasons I
will explain but but that was the rage
at the time any progressive forum would
want to have a big planning more what we
are talking about linear programming
model for those who know what that means
thousands of equations thousands of
activities five year out plans about
investment plans about production or how
they depend I integrate you know
describing sort of the inner workings of
the firm it was terrific in the sense
that it was a wonderful way for somebody
like me who was a mathematician to
actually come to learn about how a big
company works I got to work with the CEO
CFO not with the CEO a very charismatic
CFO who who was a very tough guy but
somehow Tuukka liking to me because he
liked that I said what I thought and and
he would then say when I pretty often
mean I thought wrongly but we got to go
long very well and and so I started on
this work by collecting information from
these factories and without to the
factors and talked to them and it didn't
take very long to realize that this
seemed like a pretty meaningless task in
the sense that you know what these guys
were in the factories worried about was
first of all that you know some new
gadget comes and you know somehow screws
up their life but certainly they way
gaming it you know they were sort of
asking indirectly or almost directly
questions you know what should I put in
to get maximally things out for myself
and and I I don't think they were doing
it to cheat people but they had the view
that headquarters didn't know what they
were doing and so you know they had to
somehow adjust you know not send the
numbers that were true but send some
other number so that that would kind of
correct what the headquarters thought
about so I could see that there were you
know the two sides of the problem was to
neither side somehow had the full
information and and this was a
complicated problem completely swamp in
the problem of actually calculating this
gigantic you know model which itself was
of course complicated so I suggested
that let's scan it and subsequently
heard they they thought for a moment to
fire me but the CFO saved me and said
let's put him to work on something else
and something else was very small models
incentive models and you know various
you know versions of how do we
incentivize these people in the right
way in southern looking at now pretty
pathetic but but you know I tried my
best
morals about incident incentives and and
so on and and then I got the lucky draw
which was I was awarded a scholarship to
go to Stanford for a sabbatical from
this firm
and the lucky draw really wasn't just
Stanford it was that that I realized
incentives was actually also an interest
of economists at the time and III and I
got to go to Bob Wilson's class which
was a iconic class at the business
school what Wilson subsequently became
advice I'm very glad that he is here
with with us here today and he I asked
him about the incentives and he pointed
me to to work that was worth reading
first I thought it was gibberish
but eventually I started to realize it
was actually made made kind of sense I
don't know if you will think that way so
that's that's how I ended up where I am
right now and and and I feel pretty
pleased about it so I write people for
four months and Beyond because the the I
have a very simple narrative in the
sense that you know I went there like
most people I thought that paper
performance is the thing there's sort of
medicine for incentive problems and
after 30 or so years of studying it I'm
more or less thinking paper the form
pay-for-performance to simplify is the
problem and and if this sounds like the
Republicans you know maybe this but I'm
going to start with a simple paper
performance story you know the way we
studied it in the early days and by the
way Wilson wrote a very early paper on
it in 69 and Steve Rose another friend
in 6a 73 and so on so there was a
literature that I began with and I will
start from that literature and then show
you how I developed it together with Coe
orders how I developed in it further
into the view that I was just suggesting
that that this problem is much more than
about pay for performance so I call it
the principal-agent problem that's the
land
we use I'm not going to use any
equations and such I had such flies but
I decided to take it away because I'm
trying to explain it it's a it's a
canonic model a sort of simplified model
of a c2 a complicated situation where
there's just one principle a boss say an
employee is the agent the employer is
the boss it could be a client who is the
is the boss in the case of hiring a
lawyer who is the agent it could be the
board which is the boss and the CEO who
is the agent and so on this is a model
that kind of just studies the question
of what kind of incentive pay would be
suitable in a very generic context and
there are two difficulties that makes
the model so the is the interest of the
model and that is preferences are not
aligned and performance are imperfectly
measured and these two things make the
problem a complication and I come to
that just in a second but then secondly
days that the incentive is as I said
just the contract the paste may be based
on measured performance which as I said
just a moment ago was imperfect so
that's the setup and it's good usually
we usually start by saying what is the
first best meaning what if they didn't
have these problems what would be the
solution and actually too much already
mention it but the first best cases are
- actually there are three but I want to
just mention two agents choice is
verifiable so we can actually observe
what you are doing what the employee is
doing in that case the contract is just
written so that it says do this or then
you don't get any pay or do you get to
punishment or something like that so
it's a and then because the agent
typically is risk averse and that's a I
didn't mention the risk aversion or yeah
it's a preference are not aligned I
should that means
because the agent is risk-averse and the
principle is this neutral so the agent
doesn't like to carry risk so the ideal
is to pay the agent a fixed rate if the
intern didn't have any action that would
have to be incentivized the other case
is where the agent is risk neutral in
which case though doesn't worry about
the risk and therefore could carry the
whole the whole risk for himself this is
the case we call a rental agreement or
it's the agent is to visit your claimant
just to give you a sense taxicabs
drivers typically are on this scheme
it's very difficult to measure their
performance so they actually are visit
your claimants they they rent the car
from somebody who owns the car and then
and and then get the most if if not
every all of the income from from
driving this gives the right incentives
they are like you know their own owner
and when they are driving but in the
general case the second best is in this
model one about balancing incentives
against this and rather than saying how
this he studied and so on you know let
me say my contribution to this this part
was to try to understand how this model
was thinking this is a very big part of
the way I look at this theory it's a
it's an experiment it's crucial to try
to understand what how the model thinks
and then if we can't do that then that's
not a model that I typically like to
work on so and I emphasize the fact that
sometimes you think you understand it
but you actually don't
so this informativeness principle may
sound very simple so it says that I
asked the question or actually it was
asked before the question of instead of
asking what should the incentives can
look like one preceding question is what
information is valuable for incentive
contracting and the answer sounds kind
of silly or trivial anything that is
informative
what the agents choice of action should
go into it and this is something that
seems well and I jointly discovered and
both papers were published together in
the same volume but what is not so
trivial about this is that a lot of
people actually thought at the time this
is not the case so the goal in view was
that if some signal is noisy enough
about what you are doing then it's
worthless so this is of in that sense a
surprising answer it is not the reason
another way of looking at it is to look
at an old accounting principle so if you
read accounting books in the times they
would say pain should only depend on
variables that the agent can control
sounds like a very sensible principle -
but if you look at the relative
performance to take one of the
applications of the informativeness
principle you will see that relative
performance means that if you do
something and I'm paying you for it
I may want to see somebody else who
doing something similar to you and
taking seeing how well is that person
doing and then based on that decide
whether to pay you a lot or little or or
adjust the payment by sort of the
circumstances and the point is that
because the agent is not the sole
producer of the performance measure this
lock is a bad luck or good luck that
also affects the performance measure
then filtering out something about that
noise that shouldn't be there to get a
better and more perfect performance
measure that's where the relative
performance is very very valuable so
actually taking something the agent
cannot control helps me take out
something that the agent can't control
in the original measure that's the logic
of why it is actually good and thereby
reducing the risk and when so the
controllability principle got to be
adjusted accountants change their the
way they define controllability the
measure becomes more control
thanks to relative performance about
this
I think the informativeness principle
would be talked about as much I'm not
thinking so much about it for the I
should say by the way that it has been
used now as a this this aspect of my
work has been heavily used for telling
that that CEO should be paid for not for
luck bad or good but typically for for
good luck so people you know various
corporate governance advocates are very
big on this idea that they should they
should the pace should be adjusted as a
function of macroeconomic circumstances
and so on doesn't seem to happen quite
that way and I don't want to get into
that for me the informativeness of all
this narrative the informativeness the
importance of it is that it tells
exactly actually how the model things so
the fact that that that you get this
principal holes is it's saying that all
the all the minor pieces of information
about the agents whether the agent did
what sort of was expected of the agent
is relevant for evaluating the agent
what it explains several puzzles and I
come to one just shortly but basically
explains why why the model tends to
produce extremely complicated answers
you know data you don't get a linear
scheme you don't get a necessarily or
say single bonus scheme or anything that
you see reality or option or whatnot
that's the core part of this principle
it just basically says nothing about the
shape except for very rare circumstances
so the it is always sensitive to the
information but it also by being
oversensitive
it does explain we understand exactly
how these things in one place where it
is especially cuz important is in an
example a striking example that model is
brought up in in a paper in 1976
where he basically said that if you look
at the simplest of examples mathematical
examples where the agent has put in an
effort and then you add a noise term and
the noise term is what we call normally
distributed meaning it's the very
familiar bell-shaped distribution
function that we all know about this
seems like the obvious example to look
at and this does not give a sensible
sounding answer the way the optimal
incentive actually doesn't first of all
exist but you can approximate arbitrary
closely the first best by increasingly
punishing the agent for increasingly bad
outcomes so someday far out in the tail
when you perform you were supposed to
perform at 100 and you get minus 10,000
you know then we really punish you hard
and that will keep you working just the
way I wanted and for the most part you
are just played of flat weights now poor
Milgram and I looked at this example on
row and by the way this I should say
informativeness exactly explains why
this is the case because the the model
the tail of the normal distribution is
hugely informative and so this model
sort of you're paying the person exactly
as a function of how much information
days in the outcome seeing now with
regard to whether the agent did what was
expected or not so poor Mohammed I
looked at this example and and we sort
of I had been working for a while here I
wasn't happy with this model the basic
model you know I was doing well in the
labor market that I wasn't feeling well
because this worked it seemed to be
right I mean I and the model was correct
but it wasn't giving what we wanted so I
I invite people to work on me with me
and we this was you talked about ten
days I think we spent about the week or
so and we sort of figured out it was a
simpler problem only but don't worry
I think actually we spent three hours
but yeah so a very simple answer the
Lila incentive is optimal in our model
just to cut it short is because it puts
the same incentive pressure it's not
sense it linear schemes are not
sensitive to the fine details of
information and another way of putting
it is the Morley's extremes it's a very
extreme scheme to pay you know when you
in the very tail over or over
distribution if you just change the
situation a little bit or you make
another little you know your your your
view of measurement error was not
exactly correct then it all falls apart
so the linear scheme was robust in a
sense then and this I would say that
this has led to its own literature and
it sort of shifted the literature to
boards of view where we are actually
looking at a mall where the agent just
one little thing such as the level of
effort is actually not the simplest case
to study it's about the most complicated
thing to study because the behavior of
the model is so erratic despite the
seeming simplicity and I think this is a
very important thing because a lot of
people walked around and looked at
Molly's case and said you know well
that's ridiculous let's just study
linear incentives because it's simpler
this it is not relevant for us so this
is a I mean you don't do theory in order
to just dismiss a model that says you
should really punish people at the very
tail of the distribution which is a
anything but leaner and then you say
okay thank you for the advice and then I
just go and assume something so this is
to me a very deep lesson with regard to
doing theory we do theory to listen to
what the model says and then we go and
find out by saying it and in this case
it led to the insight that we were
looking at the wrong kinds of models so
the models we want to ask in this case
that by the way the dynamic model is one
with a lot of actions
with the agent the basic intuition is
the data it has a lot more control over
his performance if he chooses things
dynamically over time against the bonus
or against the molle scheme but I don't
want to speak about the linear model
except to say that the thing that the
thing that caught the eye of Paul and me
was the fact that that the first of all
the linear model worked logically you
know it you ask you two questions you
know what about if there's less risk
well then you can pay the agent or
steeper incentive because the agent is
risk aversion what if the the agent is
less risk-averse then you also pay a
steeper incentive that is a higher
Commission what if the value of the
agents effort is high all these are
right answers let me just explain if you
had asked these questions for the first
first or the the first model I was
talking about you would get no one solo
you could get completely crazy answers
so the thing that is however hidden in
this answer and and and that shows that
when you look at this model in detail is
that that there was a little detail in
the story that we had ignored sort of
for ten years at least in in in this
which is that it also depended how much
bang for the buck you get if you raise
the incentive and this comes from the
agents cost function and it became
important because it meant that actually
you have another instrument than paying
the agent you can also perhaps change
the cost function of the agent so we got
into the idea of multitasking the idea
of multiple instruments and so let me
give just a short review of the
multitasking or some examples when you
have many tasks and in the game sort of
us changed completely it was not about
level effort it's about do do people
allocate their effort correctly and it's
actually challenging because there are
some tasks that are very easy to
and there are some types of harder
missile and you can you have to sort of
consider the fact that even though you
can easily observe one if you race a
take the quantity versus quality but
quantity usual is easy to measure
quality is hard to measure if you raise
the the incentive on call on quantity
then that makes it harder to incentivize
quality and in fact in the first
instance agent will allocate away effort
from quality into quantity and we will
see many examples like at the same
appears in short term versus long term
decisions if we push the short term you
will have a problem with the long term
and so on and and so let me jump to the
scandals which has been a bitch are very
often functions of this multitasking
problem and there is even the saying of
you get what you pay for is is one of
the problems so farewell Fogg was a very
recent case in in the u.s. you know they
bear the bells Fargo workers were found
to have manufacture I think of a million
fake accounts I mean they had names like
Holmstrom and Hart but we didn't know
that there were such accounts and and
they were used there was no money in it
but because they were paid for creating
accounts and various products and
selling them then they got bonuses and
and the life was happy for a couple of
years but no longer and now now I think
about 5000 people have been fired and
the CEO of course have to step out so
that's an example obey you start pushing
people it's not that they are evil by
the way some may be but you know that I
don't believe that that might not mikes
it's just that they are so much is
expected of them that they they in some
sort of some people lose it and they
just feel like they have to manufacture
somehow in response to what's required
in order to hold on to their job so the
BP and oil Gulf spill which is is I
think in the memory of some of you
either is a disasterous case
this and that VP will highly
incentivized I mean there are other
stories of this but I was actually
working for McKinsey at the time and so
this closely very aggressive very
aggressive top-down demands that people
should deliver you know find discover
oil palm oil you know do what the
wildcatters entrepreneurs we're doing so
well and I I think it it is clear that
that that that left led to shading in
terms of quality Enron is an example of
misaligned incentives so this is an old
problem it actually goes back to General
Motors and and Fisher body is that you
you you you have you have somebody
working for you who is actually
basically owning or subsidiary you give
the subsidiary to some incentive as
these people for the subsidiary but you
don't realize that that that they are
just going to you know they have total
imbalance there hundred percent of the
subsidiary of one percent of Enron
that's not a very see very natural
situational correct situation for
incentives and teachers are a big
subject in the u.s. right now but that
teaching the test which is not wrong in
principle but it just cuts into the
value of having teachers actually give
teach students what they also need
namely social skills verbal skills
presentation skills all that is very
hard to measure so that leads to
problems and so what is the remedy so
the remedy here and let's leave this the
sort of insight on multitasking is that
there are two ways you can stimulate say
presentation skills in school if you are
teacher one or get a teacher to to
allocate time for that one is to pay
more somehow measure after all how they
present the students and you know have
some context or have opinions about that
but the easier tasks typically don't
incentivize competing tasks
so it's actually a story that leads to
this multi stocking stories multitasking
stories very much connected to low
powered incentives that is low powered
incentives in many many situations no
incentive financial monetary pecuniary
incentives is actually the best
incentive for something else so even if
something is perfectly measurable and on
its own that task would be perfectly
incentivized first best as I called it
you actually don't do anything you don't
you know that information and you don't
you don't you pay your pace independent
of it the idea of its floats around a
lot also people have an instinct and
workers like they'll pay me for what I
can control that can be very dangerous
and damaging for the same reason because
it's easy to produce results but it's
the wrong kinds of results so I come to
the important corollary of this
multitasking is multiple instruments you
say well what do I do if I can't
incentivize I can't pay anything you
know pay for performance is not the
right rule the answer is they are inter
natives inside the firm especially and
it sort of builds on this red thing at
the bottom employees want to be
appreciated you know I've spent 13 years
enough on on the Nokia board we got
every year these yearly evaluations of
what workers like and don't like about
Nokia in the top three always I would
love to know better what my boss wants
me to do that he stays there screaming
that I've they in the forum you try to
influence people's views of you it's a
you know you want to do good perhaps but
above all you want to be appreciated you
want to know what will what will it take
to be appreciated it's a little bit like
one of the emails I got about the Nobel
Prize what should I do to get a Nobel
Prize it said you know it's a there was
another person who wanted to be
appreciated
so the other thing is so then the job
design is a very important way so you
have these sort of bigger vehicle
measures of or drivers or performance
then you can make the form has a lot of
instruments used so channeling that
energy fuel base or the desire and that
is through job design you can split up
for instance dealing with is easy to
measure hard to measure you can split up
the jobs you have two different kinds of
teachers that just teach math and those
that teach teach performance or or or
speaking skills or whatever is hard to
measure bureaucratic rules which people
tend to think I mean that's the book now
how do we incentivize is this poorly
performing performing government the
answer is in general you don't you know
the I you know when when people come
with the ideas that they should come and
bring incentive pays into the government
that is very very frustrating so I days
just here's Authority career path
supervision recruit they just tons of
the instruments inside the form so the
inside the form can first of all tap
into that much more powerfully tap into
the design desire of people to be
appreciated and that opens up all other
instruments that are non-pecuniary non
performance pay for performance
instruments so well I got the let me
just conclude by saying there's a lot
beyond pay for performance multitasking
problem this measurement problem these
are the imbalance that you get if you
have many tasks it happened it's just
not coming only for pay for performance
they are they are these career concerns
and other drivers that can lead the
problems the water point you it anti
role has a paper on it is a desire to be
appreciated leads influence costs that
Milgram and robots have talked about
by the way the asset ownership is an
instrument and and we just heard all
about talk about presence that's a
multitasking problem misalignment
problem and one of the things I just
leave you with is the bull I think the
nature of work is changing dramatically
and and you have your phones you
probably some of you are reading your
phones you're multitasking
you know you are not losing you are not
getting the valuable wisdom in this
lecture you know it's a problem and and
we can do we can't you know that's one
of the things that I think worry me a
little bit is that you don't know what
your workers are doing but you may have
to increase your punishment
significantly for for instance trying to
run as a separate business in in in
while you are doing something you
actually using your your mobile phone to
run a couple of other businesses or
whatever it is and it turns out that
punishments are getting extremely severe
for this kind of activity and that is
also it's going back to my original
informative that is actually the right
thing from the incident apart of you to
because you don't have to do that
there's no error term in that sense and
therefore the punishment should be very
severe thank you very much
I hold on I hear I forgot entirely that
here I have my whole support troops and
Bob Bilson you see my advisor is in the
top you haven't written anything
everybody else is a co order but for
Milgram is to the left and shanty roll
to the right and Oliver got a prominent
place I do remember your name
and and John Roberts unfortunately can't
be here but wonderful people Gary is
here and I think that's the people who
are here just wonderful people to work
we thank you very much sorry about that
[Applause]
thank you very much I would like to
invite professor Hart to come up on
stage
[Applause]